Ever done ends on the show ends.
Oh No.
What is it?
No thanks.
So wait a minute.
So either this,
let's try that real quick.
Do one on one.
Um,
your mother
HD
now is when table cause this rant of paint companies dance
is feeling Castro
don't even feel the effects when he says cam and it signs it being blessed.
So miles off track,
it's not smoking crack.
And once it,
his brain starts and chain me yet shared office bags,
shoes I was feeling,
he says,
announce team now is out in the stream and he lacked Jesse James [inaudible] but
even been in school.
It's nervous with it to bounce back in blood in Poo
wrap their mother
rats they snatched
kids get
we go
and
swinging
the men's.
They're wrapped the flag.
Random wearing a sham p Jews out of near glass stash and no savings.
She knew the bandits.
Shopping sprees get
keys.
You magnify.
Come on one day.
If I can match him,
I have wetlands out the battle of the books.
She's been the rich.
Some people was rammed him.
Mother
rats.
These snaps
so
far.
We go and
DMC,
they will
go nasty.
Lagging.
Matt Simpson pushing for her influence.
One disappeared.
Him
Rats,
these snapshot fall and
Sam,
Sam his game and
well faraway ago and him
rats.
They're snatched
Sam.
Sam's kids.
Good.
I am
glorious.
Absolutely glorious.
Yeah.
I never heard that acoustic version four.
I don't think I pulled it out a lot cause that mid section where I go there,
I feel like it just loses something when I go to the bridge without like an
accompany.
Yes,
but his sounded all right right there.